welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and I'm just doing a quick Channel
check-in to share some announcements
we're really excited about coming very
soon so let's put on the Kevin feige
ball cap bring me the heads of perimeter
and Alonso okay whoa whoa whoa I just
kind of blacked out there I'm sorry
about that okay starting tomorrow the
new rockstars channel will launch a new
episode rewatch series Daredevil seasons
one two and three with Daredevil Born
Again coming to the MCU next year and
production currently underway we have
been dying to go back through the first
three seasons of the Netflix Daredevil
series which are now streaming on Disney
plus and break them down properly
Episode by episode to appreciate the
themes the writing the direction the
music acting stuntwork the Marvel Easter
eggs and the gooey gooey wet poppy
violence
and with Charlie Cox Vincent d'onoprio
and John burnt though all returning for
born again this earlier era will
definitely be required viewing with so
many lessons to learn as the MCU offers
their Take On The Man Without Fear you
may remember in 2020 we did this with
the MCU with our Infinity Saga rewatch
and now in 2023 we are embarking upon
the road to born again and so we would
love for you to join us every week as we
break down a new episode of Daredevil
which again is streaming on Disney plus
now yes I realize that tomorrow is April
1st but trust me this is not an April
Fool's thing this isn't like your
teacher lying to you about having no
homework and then giving you homework
this is actually happening I promise oh
my God okay it's happening everybody
stay calm tomorrow morning somewhere
around like 11 A.M Eastern you will see
this thumbnail on the channel it's going
to be me and Jessica breaking down the
2014 pilot of Netflix's Daredevil we
found so many new things this is going
to be the perfect preview series for
born again next year now new rockstars
as a channel is actually going to use
the 30 days of April to get into shape
ahead of the summer with only the
content you really love so for the next
30 days One Premium video per day that's
really it we at new rockstars are gonna
combine our strengths we're gonna
collaborate and for the next month we're
gonna aim for quality over quantity
those 30 videos we have in April will
include of course the weekly breakdowns
for our Daredevil rewatch series I'm so
so excited and of course my weekly
Easter egg breakdown to the Mandalorian
which come on Thursdays are Wookie leaks
action shows with me and Tommy coming on
Wednesdays as always we're gonna do
breakdowns of any major movie trailers
like Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
Spider-Man across the spider-verse or
Ahsoka or anything else those Studios
surprise us with you're gonna see our
reaction and breakdown of the big news
that comes out of Star Wars celebration
on April 7th we're gonna have an
in-depth breakdown of the Super Mario
Bros movie and in-depth breakdown of the
dungeons of dragons honor among Thieves
film which is going to be coming early
next week and and each of our hosts will
be working on long form heavily
researched investigations covering
topics we don't always get to cover but
stuff that you've always asked us about
for example what makes something good
VFX or bad VFX like is everything bad or
is there a reason things are bad or feel
like they're bad or things like why are
nighttime scenes and TV shows getting
harder to see again in April you will
see on this channel just one video per
day so that's 30 videos for the month of
April I guess there might be more if
there's like a ton of big movie trailers
that we weren't expecting but the plan
is for 30 premium videos so you're gonna
want to turn those notifications on hit
that little bell feels good to do the
truth is while we began this year
wanting to cover everything there's a
lot of content and we want to take this
month to recharge to check in with all
of you and to cover those things that
you care about with that sweet sweet new
Rockstar's quality that you come to
expect from us and so how will this
programming update affect what you're
normally seeing on the channel well I'm
gonna take you through all of it our
amazing live stream show the break room
will return for a second season in May
for its one year anniversary and they're
taking April off to transition to a new
set in the new Rockstar's office as we
speak the new break room set is under
construction it's very exciting and the
actual office break room will finally be
liberated so people can have real lunch
breaks again people's keyboards are
covered in pasta now a big update this
week we learned that Marvel's secret
invasion is coming on June 21st so our
inside Marvel after show will return
then I honestly cannot wait to have
weekly MCU drops again to discuss with
my buds now I'm going to continue to
host April videos here on new rockstars
while I continue to make some content on
the Deep dive Channel 2 since we
launched in February we have been blown
away by your support of this side
Venture April 7th will be my deep dive
of interstellar and later in the month
I'll be doing re-watches of Guardians
volume 1 and Guardians volume 2. our
weekend Rogue Theory format has been a
really fun experiment for us and we're
also going to take a break from that in
April as we apply the lessons from that
experimentation to the first step of
another big announcement that we made
back in January I promise I didn't
forget about it launch pad so Launchpad
is the new pilot program we're testing
out in the year of 2023 and all new
Rockstar's team has been quietly
developing some really exciting projects
that we can't wait to share with you and
by the end of April you will learn what
our first new series will be with
episodes to release in May I don't know
what it is yet there is a Brain Trust
that's looking at a lot of exciting
options and we're gonna make that
announcement this month but the thing is
you will decide which of these series
gets renewed which gets extended which
gets Spanish Forever Until time goes by
Nostalgia sets in and suddenly everyone
wants attack of the Clones again but
seriously this 30-day born-again April
plan I just laid out it's really up to
you what those videos are like we'll
have you covered for the Mandalorian for
Daredevil the other big movies and
trailers coming in April but beyond that
please tell us what you want to see here
at new rockstars we're excited to take a
breath and do a bit of spring cleaning
and we need your help with it so thank
you so much for supporting the new
rockstars Network it just means a lot to
us that you've stuck with us as we
continue to do this experimentation we
love being able to make this nerdy
content for you and we're gonna keep
doing it the best we can reminder to
subscribe to new rockstars and in the
Deep dive and we'll see you tomorrow for
our breakdown of Daredevil episode one
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]